Good morning John.
The election here in America is tomorrow.
And we've talked about the elections every video for the last like four videos.
And I'm sure you're gonna talk about it tomorrow.
So today I want to tell you a story.
One of the best kind of stories in all of the different kinds of stories. Hot spicy summer camp stories.
Now, you're probably jumping to some conclusions right now.
The first one being that at the time of the story I was a camper with little or no experience in the ways of the world.
But you'd be wrong. This actually happened while I was a counselor at the summer camp.
Though I'm happy to say there are no campers involved.
And you might be thinking that this story is gonna take place in one of the cabins or deep in the forest.
In a starry night or at least you know like on the tennis court after dark.
But no, it happened in the kitchen.
Maybe you're imagining me and some starry eyed brunette on the painted white tables in the cafeteria,
As the winds of a summer storm howled outside.
But no, there were actually like twelve other people there.
And at the end of the night I fell asleep with an ice cube on my lips.
So are you ready?
It was late at night. A steamy august night.
A bunch of counselors and I were not on duty. And we had put the campers to sleep.
And what do you do when you are an off duty counselor and all your kids are asleep?
You raid the kitchen. That's what you do.
Sometimes you find like leftover desserts or entrees from that evenings dinner.
But no such luck on this night. We just had chips and salsa.
Which is fine because I like chips and I'm okay with salsa.
Actually at that time, I wasn't a huge salsa fan  because I didn't like spicy stuff at all.
Huge spice wuss.
And also all the chunks in salsa. Like anything that might contain actual nutritious value.
I didn't like that either.
So basically my strategy was to try and get like the flavour of the salsa on the chip.
Without getting any actual chunks on the chip.
So just getting the liquid on it.
But by favorite possible outcome in a salsa chip dipping situation.
Is that there has been a chip that has been sitting around in the salsa for a long time.
Like an oreo soakin' up all the milk. Chippy goody salsa goodness chip.
Kind of soggy. And I know that sounds gross. But I really like it.
So when I spotted a chip like covered in salsa in the salsa bowl. I was super excited about this.
So I scooped it on up with an other chip and I popped the whole thing in my mouth.
What I did not know was the story of this chip.
It had a long story. It used to be corn for example. That was a long time ago in the history of the chip.
But more recently that chip had been used by a fellow counselor who thought that the salsa was not spicy enough.
So he had doused the chip with a kind of novelty hot sauce the kind of hot sauce that says on the label "Do not
use more than one or two drops at a time."
This bottle of hot sauce contains 92,000 servings of hot sauce. And it's like this big.
The kind of hot sauce that's named like !@#$ blaster or Satan's revenge.
The kind of hot sauce that measures hotness in mega tons. And comes in bottles shaped like coffins.
And lists insanity as the first ingredient.
That kind of hot sauce. He had put on the chip and swirled around into the salsa.
And I had taken that chip that was soaked in this death sauce.
And I put it in my mouth and I chewed and I swished it around and then I turned 80 differnt colours
And I almost died.
By the end of the night I had poured a gallon of milk into a bowl and I was putting my face into it.
Because it spread out of my mouth. Insert head into milk and breathe milk.
I was in the walk in refrigerator pushing my face against things. Just like licking it.
After I finally gave up on trying to make the pain subside, I just left with a giant cup full of ice.
Went back to my cabin. Laid down with ice in my mouth and on my lips and eventually fell asleep.
When I woke up my mouth was still burning.
And the moral of this story is: vote! If you can.
Remember take a picture of yourself at your polling place or with a ballot.
And we will send you a free DFTVA sticker. And please make sure that everyone you know votes as well.
This is the one time a year when it's okay to be a little bit obnoxious. John, I'll see you tomorrow.